[Music]
watch watch
I am Justine I'm so excited because I'm
a member of the Squatch watch team now
it's been 2 years since we've last
hunted for Squatch but in that time
we've been developing some new
technology we have new food we have new
vehicles we also have new weapons but
you must remember we need to take
Squatch alive he cannot be injured
hi I am Jenna and I am a Sasquatch
aficionado I am the night vision
coordinator I have all of the newest
technology we have vests we have lasers
we have night-vision cameras and we also
have something else that is a surprise
the fear went off it's time for feeding
it's time for the feeding for home brain
ha ha ha
pretty much like to join us oh yeah I
just got recruited this man never talk
louder because I'm I don't want to be
this is Brianne she's extremely crucial
to our mission on finding Squatch
Brianne is really strong strong giddyup
Wow I hit the wrong but we had other
modes of transportation thankfully
Brianne is not one of them but she is
but one of them that was not at all safe
Steve here I'm the safety and explosives
expert for Squatch watch and as you can
see I'm in one of the least safe places
on earth right now it could be a Squatch
anywhere my main goal is gonna be
keeping these girls safe and keeping
myself safe from these girls put a start
by going through some of my gear got
IPRO keep that 20/20 vision
got this ear Pro here it is a piece of
safety equipment but it's really got
nothing to do a Squatch watch it's just
because these girls are super annoying
and sometimes I don't want to hear Bree
talk about her selfies this is by far
the best invention that we have yet with
squatches near I feel physical pain
inside of me
all from this that's a lot of buttons
he's close oh yes
nobody this way it's working one thing I
haven't been doing the past years
getting in tip-top physical condition oh
my gosh guys this is the most exciting
moment the squat reveal is here it's the
upgrade for 2013-2014 hold on I'll show
you here it is here comes here comes
oh my gosh look at it not that's what
girls never listen to me anyway
Brie's going to get finding Squatch all
revolves around the Squatch call we've
been working so hard to perfect it a lot
of breathing exercises I think that's
good now there's also a new call it's
called this sleepy sasquatch call it's a
little bit lower pitch for when
sasquatches are like sleepy or looking
for like a cuddle buddy this is a sleepy
sleepy Sasquatch calls I think we might
have got a bite did you turn we didn't
get a bite oh you're gonna call back
you're gonna call the break
get up get them come on watch a movie
get the movia we have to get going I
have to go I'm gone
this is this is it this is Jenna this
could be it real log not on the real one
I'll go get the keys get the keys give a
second 'mobile Hey all right wait wait
wait where's the GoPro I don't know - we
can't go without the bro pick me up I'm
gonna go get the GoPro
what is watching
Oh
I'm not going to lie guys on the same
you cam right now I'm in the back with
the safety vehicle but I've never felt
less safe in my life different these
girls
breanne the selfies could not be
happening oh don't read up in it Shh
your turn kiss her
okay dork do not take off free open the
door and do it all you between this out
that's a six a Squatch do you do a golf
I don't make schools
just go and see what you can find
automobile condition Bree don't forget
to be safe
Bree was deadweight just waving us down
hold us back everybody in seatbelts
safety
[Music]
pretty fit right now we're setting up
the ultimate technique that we have
developed this year this is the Squatch
snack dispersion method did you hear
that
because watch it was a Squatch all right
we need to disperse the food we're
mixing the environmentally friendly and
super safe Squatch through dispersion
system right here it's technology that
Justine has actually invented in the
last two years and this is the first
time that we're actually trying it out
in real life we're going to disperse his
food all about the forest using this
magical technique that we've developed
over the past two years safety set I
think we're ready
[Music]
one shot but I believe the Squatch food
has been dispersed evenly across the
forest so tonight when we come out
Squatch will be snacking my god what if
we're gonna get a gas shut up we're
running out again we're only gonna get
no sushi we already got a gas with me
today yeah we must have a gas that you
have okay I know really why you can get
this ass